الى اوكرانيا التي تشهد اشتباكات ضاريه في
محور باخوه حيث تدفع كييف بقواتها في
محاوله لاستعاده السيطره على المدينه التي
فقدتها منذ اكثر من شهر لقوات بينما يعلن
الجيش الروسي تصديع لعشر هجمات في انحاء
في هذه الاثناء يتصاعد القصف في انحاء
الجبهه مخلفا ضحايا
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من اكرامات
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان ما حجم
وكثافه هذا القصف الذي تتعرض له
صاروخي عنيف تعرضت له مدينه اكراماتورسك
هو الاوسع من نوعه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
لهذه المنطقه وسط مدينه كما توست تشاهدون
هذا اثر للضربه الصاروخيه بصاروخين
ضرباء هذه المنطقه وسط مدينه كرماتورسك في
هذه المنطقه الحيويه هذه المنطقه هي
الاكثر حيويه التي يرتادها السكان نحن
نتجه الان نحو اكثر الاماكن تضررا وهو هذا
المطعم هو اكبر المطاعم وسط مدينه
كرماتورسك تعرض لاضرار كبيره تعرض
لصاروخ مباشر على ما يبدو وادى ذلك الى
اضرار كبيره وتعمل فرق الانقاذ الان على
رفع الانقاض وعلى التعامل مع الضحايا في
هذا المكان على ما يبدو ان هناك ضحايا ما
زالوا تحت الانقاض في هذه اللحظه هي ضربه
من اكبر الضربات التي تعرض لها منطقه
كرماتورس شرقيه بريطانيا فرق الانقاذ ما
زالت تعمل في هذا المكان هذا المكان هو من
اكثر الاماكن حيويه الاداره العسكريه تقول
ان الضربه اتت خلال تواجد عدد كبير من
الناس تشاهدون حجم الضرر حجب حجم الدمار
في هذا المكان ونشاهد كيف ان فرق الانقاذ
تعمل على انقاذ الجرحى ما زالت اسعافات في
الداخل فرق رفع الانقاذ لانه هناك على ما
يبدو من هو تحت الانقاذ في هذا الوقت نظرا
لان هذه المنطقه منطقه من اكثر المناطق
كثافه في مدينه كرمات الشرقيه اوكرانيا
هذه المنطقه عادت تتعرض لقصف عنيف خلال
الايام الاخيره بعد اشتداد المعارك في
منطقه باكموت وها نحن نشاهد كيف ان هذه
المنطقه الاكثر حيويه في المدينه تتعرض
لهذه الضربه الصاروخيه الكبيره قبل ساعتين
تقريبا كنا في هذا المكان لانه المطعم
الوحيد الذي يعيش في منه السكان يجلسون
فيه يستطيعون الحصول فيه على نظرا لقله
الموارد في هذه المدينه التي تتعرض بشكل
متواصل للضربات الصاروخيه وهو هذا المطعم
الذي كان فيه عدد من الاشخاص عدد من
الصحفيين الذين ايضا ابلغون انهم كانوا في
هذا المكان وتعرضوا لاصابات جراء قصف هذا
المكان هذه الضربه هي من اكبر الضربات كنا
منذ الصباح نسمع اصوات القصف في هذه
المنطقه ونشاهد كيف ان هذه المنطقه تتعرض
لضربات صاروخيه متكرره في اكثر من موقع في
مدينه كرماتورسك الا اننا نشاهد الان كيف
ان هذه المنطقه تتعرض لضربه جديده كبيره
للغايه في وسط المدينه هذا هو وسط مدينه
كرماتورسك هذه المنطقه الواقعه الشرقيه
اوكرانيا تتعرض لهذه الضربه مع اشتداد
المعارك في منطقه بخموت وفي محيط منطقه
بخموت تشاهدون فرق الانقاذ عشرات اليات
السيارات تعمل في هذه في هذه الاوقات مع
فرق الانقاذ لمحا
الناس اسعاف الاشخاص
رئيس مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تحدث عن هذا
الامر تحدث عن هذه الضربه على مدينه والتي
طالت منشات هي منشات حيويه هذه الاماكن
التي نشاهدها الان هي عباره عن مباني
حيويه يرتادها السكان يرتدها ابناء هذه
المدينه التي وان كانت تتعرض بشكل متواصل
لضربات صاروخيه لكنها لا تتعرض لهذا النوع
من الضربات بهذا الكم بهذا الحجم وبهذا
المكان لانه مكان حساس للغايه هذه الضربات
تتكرر في عدد من المواقع في عدد من المدن
الاوكرانيه الشرقيه البلاد وجنوب هذه
التطورات
هجمات الصاروخيه على هذه المدينه شكرا
شكرا لك